can you tell me how to get girls as a
bigger guy
damn like is there is there a different
way to go about it
because some guys they're like really
insecure about that you don't feel like
at least for me it doesn't seem like you
have any insecurity
um
I think I think at one point it's kind
of like
I knew I see what I used to do I used to
talk to all my homeboys exes
so they would talk to a girl and I would
talk to that same [ __ ] after they done
with her so that was my little thing
like I already know them you don't gotta
I don't gotta really hop down you don't
got no they actually hated that [ __ ]
the crew
you go in there and you just hop down
because you already know you ain't got a
bagger hey think about it it's smart
think about it smart it's smart
bagger you don't gotta even approach
that's what I'm saying that's why he was
gonna snitches
I'll introduce you to my friends
because one of your skinny [ __ ] friends
right right right but maybe the girl
likes you because your personality at
the time is cool okay [ __ ] with you
because you wanted fat [ __ ] but guess
what you got in your pocket what you
know your ass
so boom now you hit her with the
you feel me nah
yeah yeah now you hit her with the like
[ __ ] I already know you I know [ __ ]
about you my homeboy then gave me the
Intel of what you like oh so you hitting
her with [ __ ] in her mind she's like
damn how you know the [ __ ] because you
was my homeboy oh you knew I jerked off
in the truck stop like what yeah not
[ __ ] she knew about you
that's what it is you know you knew
about her you get what I'm saying yeah
Sam
hold on one God damn it hold on
oh my God that's me yeah you have to do
dirty man how's Middle School right
there so imagine you hook up with this
dude and all of a sudden this dude is
hitting you up
[Laughter]
I remember that that white girl right
there was like the most popular white
girl in our school White
her name's like Lauren I think Lauren
Hill Lauren Hill blacks yeah I remember
that girl though she was a very popular
one we got the Jay Leno like she was
like the go-to girl that all the other
dudes wanted peripheral she was the
number one girl she was like top she was
like top three you should go shot the
school no I never really shot myself one
of my homeboys didn't talk to her yeah
then I probably would have followed up
yo can I just ask you a question like is
that a is that a like a shell necklace
yeah that's that that's the shark tooth
that's that shark two [ __ ] we actually
used to be yeah yeah oh man
back then in the day I even said it on
my page back then that was like having
like a gold necklace that was that was a
bust down watch
that white shark two [ __ ] see yeah
people don't know about it like back in
the day everybody was wearing Hollister
and Abercrombie and Fitch you know uh
Aeropostale I think the American Eagle
of that got the actual gold chain is
like
above everybody no I didn't I didn't
write this I didn't write this is
somebody else's yearbook okay
yeah yeah yeah that's wild yeah I I
didn't write that did you just say Juke
Nazis
this is
this is a hell of a time peripheral that
was high school yeah no that was Middle
School oh that was Middle School yeah
Middle School oh wow
high school they stopped the whole black
boy white boy swag after a while
it was like this thing that everybody
was doing like
you don't know about Travis Porter Do
you no it's a rap group that started
black boy white boy swag it was like
they mixing the swag of each
um
race together and putting it in one okay
so that's why I was wearing the shark
you only named two races what'd you take
from Mexicans or
people we didn't not no no I think they
had their own [ __ ] though they had their
own swag the Mexicans used to be wearing
only Aeropostale they only work yeah
yeah how'd they pronounce it
interesting question
so black boy white boy swag that was a
thing and so the white boy swag was the
shark's tooth necklace yeah and the
Hollister and [ __ ] and then like
the black swag that you mix with that
you'll have like a
you had like some ripped jeans and [ __ ]
then you'll sag him yeah
some [ __ ] like that yeah he gets it